بعد تاهل منتخب مصر بشق الانفس الى الوري
ال 16 من بطوله كاس امم افريقيا كان على
منتخب الفراعنه مواجهه منتخب جمهوريه
الكونغو الديمقراطيه اذ ما اراد مصالحه
جماهيره والمرور الى دور الربع النهائي من
البطوله القاريه جرت المباراه على ملعب
لوران بوكو في سان بيدرو في الكوديفوار
سجلت الكونجو الديمقراطيه الهدف الاول قبل
ان يدرك الفراع
التعادل من ركله جزاء سجلها اللاعب مصطفى
محمد نهايه الشوط الاول بعد انتهاء الوقت
القانوني والاضافي للمباراه بالتعادل اتجه
الفريقان الى ركلات الترجيح وهي الخافضه
الرافعه لتنتهي بفوز الكونغو بنتيجه وصلت
الى ثمانيه لسبعه بعد ان اهدر الحارس محمد
ابو جبل ركله الترجيح الحاسمه للفراعنه
رواد منصات التواصل والجماهير المصريه
شنوا هجوما حادا على اللاعبين والمدير
الفني بسبب ما سموه الاداء السيء والخروج
من البطوله القاريه بدون فوز ولو يتيم
البعض الاخر طالب باقاله مدرب المنتخب
بينما طالب اخرون عبر وسم استقاله اتحاد
الكره برحيل الاتحاد المصري لكره القدم
بالكامل روي فيتوريا مدرب الفراعنه علق
بعد المباراه قائلا هذه ليست النهايه لم
نتوقع الهزيمه سوء الحظ كان السبب في
خساره مصر امام الكونغو الديمقراطيه
اعددنا هذا المنتخب لبطوله افريقيا لكن
هناك اوقات تبذل فيها كل جهدك والنتيجه لا
تكون كما كنت تتوقع علينا ان نركز على
اهدافنا المقبله اذا تغريدات كثيره على
مواقع التواصل الاجتماعي نبداها هنا بحساب
سمير يقول هو ليه الغضب ده كله دي لعبه
والخساره وارده وكلنا عارفين انه منتخبنا
مش في احسن حالاته المفروض نطبطب على
اللعيبه ونحفز مش نكرههم في الحياه ايضا
نصل مع محمد الجزار يقول اسوا اداره فنيه
ممكن تشوفها بحياتك الصراحه في ماتش
الكونجو عك كروي في منظومه تتفنن في تشويه
كل ما هو جميل رحيل فيتوريا بمفرده ليس
الحل ولكن من جاء به
قبله ايضا نصل الى اشرف يقول اصرار على
تكرار الاخطاء بل والتجويد في ابرازها
العادي دائما نزيد مع الماتشات في
البطولات المجمعه انما حصل العكس من سيء
لاسوا اقاله فيتوريا والمجلس الى غير رجعه
اخيرا
احمد يقول احمد هنا تعودنا انه يكون ابو
جبل سدا منيعا لكن في هذه المباراه اداءه
كان سيء سيئا جدا وغير منطقي لم يكن حاضرا
في المباراه اذا سلسله من التغريدات صبت
جم غضبها على حارس مرمى الفراعنه محمد ابو
جبل وحملته الجزء الاكبر من المسؤوليه عن
خروج المنتخب لاضاعت ركله الجزاء التي
تسببت في مغادره مصر للبطوله البعض اتهم
ابو جبل بانه كان فاقد للتركيز في
المباراه بعد ان راجت تقارير اعلاميه عن
اتفاق بين اداره نادي الاهلي والبنك
الاهلي على ضم محمد ابو جبل لم مده سته
اشهر على سبيل الاعاره مقابل مقابل مادي
فقط دون وجود اي صفقات
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
تبادليه